Deadpool is one of superhero comics' most
unlikely success stories.
The crass, violent mercenary has gone from
a cult favorite to the face of a smash hit
film franchise.
But while Deadpool's antics on the big screen
have been hilarious, not everything in the
comics has been quite so funny.
Here's a look at some things Marvel wants
you to forget about Deadpool.
He's a murderous psychopath
In the movies, Deadpool is a killer with a
conscience.
In Marvel's head-scratchingly popular Deadpool
Kills line of comics, though, he just ruthlessly
murders everyone he can get his hands on.
Among the most gruesome distasteful moments
is when he straight up murdered his friend
Spider-Man - by shooting him in the face - and
then there was the time he slaughtered the
X-Men and then wore Beast's furry skin like
a coat.
Once Marvel Comics finished having Deadpool
psychotically slaughter its own roster of
characters, they had him move on to other
characters, this time from the pages of famous
works of literature, wantonly butchering everyone
from Moby Dick to Ebenezer Scrooge to Bagheera
from the Jungle Book.
"That's gross."
He's in love with death
In the Marvel Universe, Death takes the form
of a woman, and is most often seen being courted
by the big purple one himself, Thanos.
But during Wade's time under experimentation
in the Weapon X program, he finds himself
frequently so close to dying that he can see
and communicate with her - and he falls in
love, trying to die just to be with her.
However, Death's jealous ex Thanos eventually
uses his powers to make Deadpool immortal,
keeping him away from Death permanently.
Considering Deadpool's romance with Vanessa
is the soul of the first film, chances are
good you won't see her and the living embodiment
of mortality squaring off in any upcoming
Deadpool flicks.
He's served himself as a cannibalistic snack
For a time, Deadpool was a member of the Uncanny
X-Force, a team that took care of the tasks
too dirty for the X-Men to face.
"We will be known as…
X-Force!"
"Isn't that a little derivative?"
"You're absolutely right!"
At the end of a particularly brutal battle,
Deadpool's teammate Archangel finds himself
in rough shape.
To help nurse him back to health, Deadpool
ends up feeding Archangel chunks of Deadpool's
own flesh - in order to lend Archangel some
of Deadpool's superhuman healing factor.
It works, but it's also… incredibly disturbing.
He's basically a complete ripoff
While it's been an open secret among comic
book collectors for decades, it might surprise
fans of the Deadpool movies to learn that
the character is actually a complete and intentional
ripoff of the DC Comics character Deathstroke,
who predated Deadpool by several years.
Deadpool creator Rob Liefeld was such a huge
fan of Deathstroke that he copied not just
the costume an d weapon choice, but the character's
name as well.
Deadpool, Deathstroke...
you get the idea.
Writer Fabian Niceiza figured Liefeld's ripoff
was so obvious they might as well just acknowledge
it.
So, he decided to give Deadpool's secret identity
the name Wade Wilson as an homage to Deathstroke,
whose real name is Slade Wilson.
Hey, subtlety has never exactly been a strong
suit for Mr. Pool.
His mental health issues are played for laughs
Given that he's a murderous psychopath who
thinks killing is hilarious, is in love with
death, and promotes cannibalism, it's pretty
safe to say that Deadpool has some fairly
serious mental health issues.
Unfortunately, in the comics, those issues
are played for laughs when he ends up choosing
reformed supervillain Doctor Bong for a therapist.
And that's kinda not even the worst part.
Marvel has consistently portrayed mental health
professionals as literal supervillains who
manipulate people in need for their own ends.
So look, Deadpool is really funny...but his
mental health struggles kind of aren't.
Especially when, as part of his "therapy,"
Deadpool sucker punched Kitty Pryde.
It wasn't even as funny as Doctor Bong's classic
appearances as Howard the Duck's archenemy.
Talk about things Marvel would really like
movie fans to forget!
"You think I might find happiness in the animal
kingdom, Ducky?"
"Like they say, doll: 'Love's strange.'
We could always give it a try!"
"That's gross."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!